a lot of people from the polish
community spent their evening with the
church service to pray for ukraine
victoria saha joining us live outside
our lady of las vegas church with more
on the support ukraine is getting
locally
on this ash wednesday parishioners
wanted to do more to start off this lent
season they gathered here at our lady of
las vegas to pray for peace and to let
ukrainians know they aren't alone
[Applause]
the congregation was filled with
churchgoers wednesday evening
symbolizing ash wednesday but also
putting the power of prayer to the test
we asked god to help them father jerry
grubchinsky has a polish background he
led his polish parishioners in prayer as
their neighboring country is dealing
with the attacks from russia
we saw that in the second world war and
how the nazis and all that invaded
poland and the suffering that went along
with that now there is a time to pay
that back other parishioners like david
kowalski says he fears history will
repeat itself if he succeeds is that he
won't stop
and the polish people are very fearful
that
they will be next people outside the
polish community in las vegas are also
doing what they can to help a new trend
is starting with people booking airbnbs
in ukraine for families in need i think
the one i did was like 22 per night
but it's a nice way to help families
directly and get the money to them now
instead of having to wait for assistance
katie baird shared her bookings with her
friends on facebook and it went viral
causing many others to do the same you
always hope if it's a good cause that
people will help i mean if it was the
united states in their position i'd hope
people would help us
the church here was gathering funds
during mass to send to those in poland
helping ukrainians if you would like to
help we have a full list up on our
website at eight newsnow dot com with
various organizations needing donations
reporting live tonight victoria zaha
live local now